Hey, listener, and welcome to Smart List. Before we get into this incredible episode, I want just a moment of your time to set the stage a little bit. Sean and Jason and I went on a smart list tour last year where we recorded 10 episodes live in front of thousands of our biggest fans from Brooklyn to Los Angeles. And guess what? Right now there are more live episodes from our tour on Wondry Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free on Wondry Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early
嘿，听众朋友们，欢迎收听《Smart Less》。在我们进入这个精彩的节目之前，我只想占用大家一点时间来做个铺垫。去年，肖恩、杰森和我进行了“Smart Less”巡演，我们在布鲁克林到洛杉矶的数千名忠实粉丝面前现场录制了10期节目。你们猜怎么着？现在，Wondry Plus上有更多我们在巡演中的现场节目供大家收听。大家可以在Wondry Plus上提前四周收听这些节目，并且没有广告，大家可以在Wondry Plus上收听。你们可以在提前四周收听这些节目
and add free on Wondry Plus, after which you can hear them for free wherever you get your podcast. Find Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. All right. Welcome to SmartLess. Wait, wait, is he an announcement over?
并且在Wondry Plus上享受免广告收听，之后你们可以在任何获取播客的地方免费收听它们。在Wondry App或Apple Podcasts上查找Wondry Plus。好了。欢迎收听SmartLess。等等，等等，他的公告结束了吗？
No one out. Oh, did he finish? He finished. Okay, great. Okay, that means we can start. The tentacle show. Tentacle show. Tentacle show.
没人出来。哦，他结束了吗？他结束了。好吧，太好了。好吧，这意味着我们可以开始了。触手秀。触手秀。触手秀。
Tentacle show. Tentacle show. Tentacle show. Do we remember what city we're in? Do we remember what city we're in? We're in Brooklyn. New York City. New York City.
触手秀。触手秀。触手秀。我们还记得我们在哪个城市吗？我们还记得我们在哪个城市吗？我们在布鲁克林。纽约市。纽约市。
Tentacle show. You might be a little tight. Yeah, excellent. Good energy. You have energy. You have. Yeah, that's a good energy. You have energy. You have that. Let's make that look like a bubble. OK.
触手秀。你可能有点紧张。对，太棒了。充满活力。你有活力。你有。对，这是一个很好的活力。你有活力。你有那个。让我们把它弄得像个气泡一样。好。
Oh! I contact. I contact. I contact. I contact. What is the name of the show we're doing? What is the show? It's SmartLash.
哦！眼神接触。眼神接触。眼神接触。眼神接触。我们做的节目的名字是什么？节目叫什么？是SmartLash。
SmartLash. So this is, uh, uh, uh, uh, bananas for us. Yeah. Um, and so to be out here for you guys truly, it is. It is so serious. Super humbling for us. And so, to be out here for you guys truly, it is super humbling for us. Thank you, thank you, thank you. Yeah, yeah. Thank you. That's a new switch.
SmartLash。所以这，呃，呃，呃，对我们来说简直太疯狂了。是的。嗯，能真正来到这里为你们表演，这真的是。这太严肃了。对我们来说非常荣幸。所以，能真正来到这里为你们大家表演，对我们来说真的非常荣幸。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。对，对。谢谢。这是一个新的开关。
I'm sitting over there. I'm sitting there. Where you want to sit? I can sit down. I sit in the middle. You're not to get because you guys are seated. This is tonight's my guest. So I get the couch.
我坐在那边。我坐在那儿。你想坐哪儿？我可以坐下来。我坐中间。你不用去，因为你们都坐着。这是今晚我的嘉宾。所以我得到这张沙发。
Yeah. Yeah. Why is that good news? You don't know. Yeah, why is that good news? Yeah, why is news? I feel like, yeah. Jay, but I'm telling you, it's a good guest. This is our last show here in Brooklyn. And I know, we're bummed to leave, believe me. Well, wait, hang on, what are you guys doing tomorrow? Yeah, that's good point.
对。对。为什么这是好消息？你不知道。对，为什么这是好消息？对，为什么是消息？我觉得，呃。杰，但我告诉你，这是个好嘉宾。这是我们在这里布鲁克林的最后一场演出。我知道，我们要离开很难过，相信我。好吧，等等，等一下，你们明天打算做什么？对，说得好。
We'll do like a little matinee. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, we should have done that. Everyone's got a rest tomorrow. You got to go to church. You've got to go to... Whatever I do. Yep.
我们要办个小型日场秀。对，对，对。哦，我们本来应该那么做的。明天大家都有空休息。你得去教堂。你得去……不管我做什么。是的。
I like to talk about things that we go through on tour, because we've never been on tour before. And one of the things is touring and traveling. We stay in the same room, which is true. The same suite. Yeah, we're seeing the same hotel room. Yeah, so by so far, everyone we've been to, every city we've been to, out of the three rooms,
我喜欢谈论我们在巡演中经历的事情，因为我们以前从来没有去巡演过。其中一件事就是巡演和旅行。我们住在同一个房间，这是真的。同一个套房。是的，我们住的是同一个酒店房间。是的，所以到目前为止，我们去过的每个人，我们去过的每个城市，在这三个房间里，
I've gotten the handicap room. Yeah. By the way, true story. It's just crazy luck. So the shower And. By the way, true story. True story. It was just crazy luck. So the shower is level with the floor, and it's a hand thing. I'm like, what? Like, it's no shower head.
我都拿到了残疾人房间。是的。顺便说一句，真实的故事。这纯粹是疯狂的运气。所以淋浴间和。顺便说一句，真实的故事。真实的故事。这纯粹是疯狂的运气。所以淋浴间与地板齐平，而且有一个手持的东西。我说，什么？就像，它没有淋浴喷头。
Which is, yeah. What? It's just right, yeah. Yeah, it's a complaint. Yeah. I saved it for here. Right. Yeah, so I can play.
也就是，是的。什么？就在那儿，是的。是的，这是一个抱怨。是的。我把它留到这里说。对。是的，所以我可以抱怨。
Why do you want to do it in front of all these thousands of people just to make us feel bad? Well, here's the other thing that I didn't talk about, which is, I don't know how you guys feel, but like, you're real. No, like, when you go out to eat at a restaurant, and you order, first of all, the waiter comes around and it's like, would you like bottled water or tap water
你为什么想在成千上万的人面前说这个，只是为了让我们觉得糟糕吗？好吧，这里还有一件事我没说，那就是，我不知道你们怎么想，但是，你们是真的。不，就像，当你在餐馆吃饭时，你点餐，首先，服务员过来，然后说，你想喝瓶装水还是自来水
or whatever, and if I go, I'll have bottled water. And everybody else will be like, hey, it's great. And then he brings a glass for every single person. And you're like, I don't have selfish, but I'm like, you have bottled. There goes my bottle of water to everybody else. So that's what part of that bothers you. I want to get down.
随便什么，如果我说，我要瓶装水。然后其他人会说，嘿，这很棒。然后他给每个人都拿了一个杯子。然后你会想，我不是自私，但我想，你有瓶装水。我的瓶装水就这么分给其他人了。所以这就是让你烦恼的一部分。我想说清楚。
Well, just whatever you want, you order that drink, but know that it was the thing I ordered. OK, I know. But is it the money? No, it's not the money. It's not the money. But here's the thing that's even worse. If I were to dessert, and these guys know, I love dessert.
好吧，不管你想要什么，你点那个饮料，但要知道那是点的东西。好吧，我懂。但这是为了钱吗？不，不是为了钱。不是为了钱。但更糟糕的是这个。如果我要一份甜点，这些家伙都知道，我喜欢甜点。
Angel loves a sweet. Yeah. If it's the same thing with those, so you know, like when you're like, okay, does anyone, and everyone's like, no, no, dessert for me. Nothing for me. And I was like, I'll have the chocolate cake,
安吉喜欢甜食。是的。如果对他们来说也是一样，所以你知道的，就像当你问，好吧，有人要吗，然后每个人都说，不，不，我不要甜点。我什么都不要。然后我说，我要巧克力蛋糕，
the oozing chocolate cake with the vanilla ice cream. Great. And then the waiter comes around plate and a spoon, plate and a spoon, plate and a spoon, plate and a spoon. And I was like, well, now I'm gonna ask the whole if I don't share, and I look like a kid, like I don't wanna share my food. But then, you know, you can't win.
那个流心的巧克力蛋糕配香草冰激凌。太棒了。然后服务员拿来盘子和勺子，盘子和勺子，盘子和勺子，盘子和勺子。然后我想，好吧，现在我要问全场如果我不分享的话，我会看起来像个孩子，好像我不想分享我的食物。但是然后，你知道，你赢不了。
I, um, and by the way, the point is, the point is that's happened when the cookies came the other day, and you're like, look, there's cookies, and this one's like, I don't want any. Let me have one. So, right. Then the cookies were next to.
我，嗯，顺便说一句，重点是，重点是前几天饼干端上来的时候就是这样，然后你们说，看，有饼干，然后这个人说，我不要。给我来一个。所以，对。然后饼干就在旁边。
OK. OK. Eight plates of food. OK. So, let's just guess something, Claire. So, if you've listened to podcast, you know that Jason has a very dangerous relationship with food.
好吧。好吧。八盘食物。好吧。所以，让我们来猜猜，克莱尔。所以，如果你听过这个播客，你就会知道杰森和食物有着非常危险的关系。
No, I just don't eat like, I don't eat like King Arthur. No, no, but you don't need to talk about it all the time. And I can't wait. I just find it fascinating. I'm going to pay for your, whatever your psychiatrist, when they deal with this because it's so fucked up. And we live in a world where everybody's always talking about food and it's a gluten free and a thing and a thing and an amity calorie.
不，我只是不吃，我不像亚瑟王那样吃。不，不，但你不需要一直谈论它。我简直迫不及待。我只是觉得这太迷人了。我要帮你付钱，不管你的精神病医生怎么处理这个问题，因为这太他妈糟糕了。我们生活在一个每个人都在谈论食物的世界里，有无麸质的，有这个的，那个的，还有卡路里。
But who fucking cares? You want to know what happens when I eat gluten? It's a disaster. It's a disaster. So close to fear. Look at them. So I get some food for lunch and then... But like, say what you have ordered.
但谁他妈在乎？你想知道我吃面筋会发生什么吗？那是一场灾难。那是一场灾难。太接近恐惧了。看看他们。所以我午餐吃了一些食物，然后……但比如，说说你点了什么。
Okay, so I ordered a burger and a steak. Keep going. That's true. That's true. Just ordered. Okay, so I ordered a burger and a steak. Keep going. That's true. That's true. Just split. No, no. You ordered a hamburger and a steak and a bowl of cream corn something and a salad. And blueberry pancakes. And blueberry pancakes.
好吧，所以我点了一个汉堡和一个牛排。继续。这是真的。这是真的。刚刚点完。好吧，所以我点了一个汉堡和一个牛排。继续。这是真的。这是真的。刚刚分着吃。不，不。你点了一个汉堡、一个牛排、一碗奶油玉米什么的，还有一个沙拉。还有蓝莓煎饼。还有蓝莓煎饼。
No, that was not even the same meal. That was a different, no. That was a different meal. And then these chocolate chip cookies, they said fresh, like, yeah, who's not gonna get that? Listen, you don't want to be rude, right? I don't want to be rude. Anyway, he's shame, he tried to shame me,
不，那甚至不是同一顿饭。那是另一顿，不是。那是另一顿饭。然后这些巧克力豆曲奇，他们说很新鲜，就像，对啊，谁不会买那个呢？听着，你不想显得粗鲁，对吧？我不想显得粗鲁。不管怎样，他在羞辱我，
which put me on the attack. I will admit to that. Yeah. And then out of spite, he just ideed it all. Yeah. And he's like, can't get it. But then you ate some of it. I had a corner of a cookie just to release the valve.
这让我进入了攻击状态。我承认这一点。是的。然后出于恶意，他把它们全吃光了。是的。然后他说，拿不到。但接着你吃了一部分。我吃了一个曲奇饼的角，只是为了释放压力阀。
You know, I mean, you start to look at something and then if you build up this... I honestly can't believe I heard in Brooklyn we're talking about this as well. I know, but you are the king. Jason, you are the king of... Not for me. What do you got there?
你知道我的意思，你开始看着某种东西，然后如果你积累了这个……我简直不敢相信我在布鲁克林听到我们也在谈论这个。我知道，但是你是国王。杰森，你是……的国王。对我不适用。你那儿有什么？
Yeah. Right. And Sean, on the other hand, he will go to People's Houses and bring McDonald's with him. Absolutely. Oh. Oh.
是的。对。而肖恩呢，他会去别人家做客，还自己带麦当劳。绝对的。哦。哦。
I hope... Sean, Sean, you're a trick if you're constipated. I just do that. Get up. I do this. This works, guys. And then it is... Seven times and things start to come out.
我希望……肖恩，肖恩，如果你便秘了，你就是个骗子。我只是这样做。起来。我这样做。这招管用，伙计们。然后是……七次，然后东西就开始出来了。
So you held it at three there. That's a... It's a whole thing, guys. You don't want to share a room with these two, ever. And food, it's tricky for you, because also you get real snacky at night now. Yeah. Well... Well, listen. Well, let's go ahead.
所以你在那里卡在了第三次。那是一个……这是一个整体的问题，伙计们。你永远不想和这两个人合住一个房间。而且食物对你来说也很棘手，因为你现在晚上也真的很想吃零食。是的。好吧……好吧，听着。好吧，我们继续吧。
You got me. She heard it. Got me. Guys, it's legal, let's go ahead. You got me, she heard it. You got me, I mean, well, guys, it's legal. It's legal now. Yeah. I mean, why do I have to hide that? No, you don't. You guess what? It's like going down to the corner and buying a six-year repair.
你抓到我了。她听到了。抓到我了。伙计们，这是合法的，我们继续吧。你抓到我了，她听到了。你抓到我了，我是说，好吧，伙计们，这是合法的。现在合法了。是的。我的意思是，我为什么要隐瞒这个？不，你不用。你猜怎么着？这就像去街角买个六瓶装的啤酒一样。
There are more dispensaries in California than Starbucks. Yeah. It's true. Yet I still will not tell my kids that daddy had choice to come but like, don't tell them. But it's mostly for the CBD. You know, it's inflammation and whatnot. Yeah, inflammation. What's amazing is people used to get,
加州的药房比星巴克还多。是的。这是真的。然而，我仍然不会告诉我的孩子们，爸爸有大麻可以抽，但是，就像，不要告诉他们。但这主要是为了CBD。你知道，是为了消炎什么的。是的，炎症。最神奇的是，人们曾经得到，
I feel like when you're going up, people get high. Like in my age You get high and you watch like the song remains the same Led Zeppelin or you'd they know what it is. Yeah, and then like Yeah, the only but like he just takes a gummy and watches MSNBC and I love something so super weird and sad about that. No, but Jay got me on them and they really work and they're very healthy.
我觉得当你长大的时候，人们会嗨起来。就像在我这个年纪，你会嗨起来，然后看齐柏林飞艇的《The Song Remains the Same》之类的，或者他们知道那是什么。是的，然后像，是的，唯一的，但他只是吃一颗软糖，然后看MSNBC，我对此感到非常奇怪和悲伤。不，但是杰让我开始吃它们，它们真的很管用，而且非常健康。
And the only, the stevia sweeten gummies. Yeah, stevia, and he will, it's the only time, the only time I will find golf interesting is he will put it on, and I'm like, what is this? Bluff, 10 minutes later, I'm like, this is amazing. Huh. Huh. Um, is it legal here, yes?
而且唯一，甜叶菊甜味的软糖。是的，甜叶菊，他会，这是唯一的一次，我唯一一次觉得高尔夫很有趣的时候，他会把它打开，然后我说，这是什么？布拉夫，10分钟后，我说，这太神奇了。哈。哈。嗯，这里合法吗，是的？
Yeah. That's like, let's get on with it. What's crazy is how much about our eating habits and stuff? They obviously know from listening to the podcast. What else are we going to talk about? I don't know. Journalists, we're not smart, we're just people that eat and sleep like everyone else.
是的。那就像，我们继续吧。疯狂的是，关于我们的饮食习惯和诸如此类的事情？他们显然是从听播客中知道的。我们还要谈论什么？我不知道。记者，我们并不聪明，我们只是像其他人一样吃喝拉撒的普通人。
It's so true. It's so boring. Well, again, we do wanna say thank you for allowing this to happen in that you guys. Yeah. Yeah. And then you listen to the podcast at all. For us, for us it was such a goof to do it.
太对了。太无聊了。好吧，再次感谢你们允许这一切发生，你们。是的。是的。然后你们根本不听播客。对我们来说，对我们来说，做这件事真是一个恶作剧。
And then to be able to do this, it's such an incredible thrill. So we're really excited to be here with you guys tonight. Thank you guys. Very excited. Very excited. So speaking of smart, which we are not, air go smartness, right? We decided to, we decided to, every once in a while,
然后能够做到这一点，这真的是一种难以置信的刺激。所以我们今天晚上很高兴能和大家在一起。谢谢大家。非常兴奋。非常兴奋。所以说到聪明，我们并不聪明，因此叫“smartness”，对吧？我们决定，我们决定，每隔一段时间，
invite somebody really, really smart. Okay, most of the time they're just our fancy, famous friends that are an easy booking for us because they're there having gummies and watching NBC with us. But tonight, folks, dash, stuff, I need to write my intros because I'm not smart nor young. Oh, listen, stuff's been a challenge for the last few years. But there are heroes out there that are working tirelessly to try to make it better. We got one of them here tonight. She's one of yours, New York. She's born in the Bronx,
邀请一个非常非常聪明的人。好吧，大多数时候他们只是我们的时尚名流朋友，对我们来说很容易预约，因为他们就在那里和我们一起吃软糖看NBC。但是今晚，各位，破折号，材料，我需要写我的开场白，因为我既不聪明也不年轻。哦，听着，过去几年里材料一直是个挑战。但外面有英雄们在不知疲倦地工作，试图让情况变得更好。今晚我们这里就有一位。她是你的人，纽约。她出生在布朗克斯，
educated in Boston, lives a lot in DC. And in fact, at 29, she was the youngest elected ever to the Congress. Guys, welcome, Alexandra Acosta, and Alexandra Acosta. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
在波士顿受教育，大部分时间住在华盛顿特区。事实上，在29岁时，她成为了国会历史上最年轻的当选议员。伙计们，欢迎亚历山德拉·奥卡索，还有亚历山德拉·奥卡索。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. You can't let us all know. Oh my God.
哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。哦，我的天哪。你不能让我们所有人知道。哦，我的天哪。
You are. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. That was so good. Right, I mean, see, this kind of stuff blows our mind. Here we are, just three dendons. It's crazy.
你是。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。噢，天哪。太棒了。对，我的意思是，你看，这种事情让我们大开眼界。我们在这里，只是三个笨蛋。这太疯狂了。
You can talk about golf with us. Yes. I wish you brought on somebody with opinions. Right. Right. Go. We're going to get him tonight. We're going to get him out of her. I got questions and stuff like that.
你可以跟我们聊聊高尔夫。是的。我希望你带一个有观点的人来。对。对。走吧。我们今晚要抓住他。我们要从她嘴里问出点东西。我有问题之类的。
First of all, are you currently in town or do you come up for this? Or how often do you get to live in your home city and versus living in DC? So this is one of those common questions I get asked. It depends on the year. Off to a great start. Oh.
首先，你目前在城里还是专门为这个来的？或者你多久能回你的家乡住一次，相比于住在华盛顿特区？所以这是我经常被问到的常见问题之一。这取决于年份。开局不错。哦。
All right. What it would tell me about your digs in DC. Do you guys all have to stay in the same kind of place? Is it like dormitories? Do you get a budget for an apartment or? OK. So if you're a normal person. See, guys, I'm going to ask shit you you never even thought to ask a congressman
好吧。跟我说说你在华盛顿特区的住所吧。你们都必须住在同一种地方吗？就像宿舍一样？你们有公寓的预算吗，还是？好吧。所以如果你是一个正常人。看，伙计们，我要问一些你甚至从未想过去问国会议员的破事
Do you take the express train to do you see it's gonna be better are you on a gummy I don't know but are you It's like a semi legal in New York. God be okay. Oh, is it is it really only semi legal? Yeah, yeah, it's decriminalized legal in New York. Got me. Is it really only semi-legal? Yeah. Yeah, it's decriminalized. Well, so what does that mean?
你坐特快列车去华盛顿吗？这会更好吗？你吃了软糖吗？我不知道，但你是……这在纽约半合法。上帝保佑，好吧。哦，真的只半合法吗？是的，是的，在纽约非刑事化合法。抓到你了。真的只半合法吗？是的。是的，它非刑事化了。好吧，那是什么意思？
It's decriminalized. It's medically legal. And it's like on the way to becoming. So wait, but so you can buy it legally if you smoke it at illegal? No, no, you can own it. Can you use it? You can use it.
它是非刑事化的。它是医疗合法的。而且就像正在成为……的路上。等等，但是所以你可以合法购买，如果你抽的话是非法的？不，不，你可以拥有它。你能使用它吗？你可以使用它。
It's decriminalized, but decriminalized. You can't buy it in a shop yet. All right. All right. But we're on our way. Yeah, I know. You can buy it in an alley. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
它是非刑事化的，但只是非刑事化。你还不能在商店里买到它。好吧。好吧。但我们在路上了。是的，我知道。你可以在小巷里买到。对，对，对。
We're apart. We're apart. We're apart. We're apart. We're apart. We're apart. We're apart. Okay, so your place in DC, you do get a budget for housing
我们是……我们是……我们是……我们是……我们是……我们是……我们是……好吧，你在华盛顿特区的住所，你确实有住房预算
or you gotta stand at yourself. Okay. No, this is not. No, no, no, no. I want to know too. So, your place in DC, do you get a budget for housing or you gotta stand at yourself? No, this is not a special thing. No, no, no, no, no. I want to know too. I have 10,000 questions I could ask you. Because I'm the dumbest person. Well, no, it's, wait in line.
还是得自己解决？好吧。不，这不是。不，不，不，不。我也想知道。所以，你在华盛顿的住所，你有住房预算还是得自己解决？不，这不是什么特殊的事情。不，不，不，不，不。我也想知道。我有1万个问题想问你。因为我是最笨的人。好吧，不，这，排队吧。
The detail, like it is crazy, it is really interesting because most people who get elected to Congress are independently wealthy before they run. I want to get into that too. And so, if you're a normal person and you get elected, like, there's no housing allowance, so you have to pay to rents. And, uh...
细节，就像这很疯狂，真的很有趣，因为大多数当选国会议员的人在参选前都已经是独立富豪了。我也想深入探讨这一点。所以，如果你是一个普通人并且当选了，就像，没有住房补贴，所以你必须自己付房租。还有……
You're placed at home and you're placed in the studio. Yeah, or like, when I got elected, my job right before was that I was bar-tending. And there's... What was a bar, shout-out to? Shout-out to the Taco Shop on Union Square, which is still there. Really?
你在家里的地方和你在工作室的地方。是的，或者就像，当我当选时，我之前的工作是当酒保。还有……那是个什么酒吧，给个 shout-out？向联合广场的 Taco Shop 致敬，它还在那里。真的吗？
Hey, some people know it! So you have to pay for two places. Yeah. And you're doing it when you go there, you're doing it on a bartender salary with the last salary you... Yeah, so basically there's kind of this weird period where after you get elected,
嘿，有些人知道！所以你必须付两个地方的房租。是的。而且你去做这件事的时候，你是拿着酒保的薪水，用你上一份薪水……是的，所以基本上有这么一个奇怪的时期，在你当选之后，
your first paycheck comes at Congress, you get paycheck monthly, okay? You get paid once a month. Yeah. And so your first paycheck comes at the end of your first month in Congress. So like how do you tide yourself over? You last that first month.
你的第一张国会薪水发下来，你是按月拿薪水的，好吧？你一个月拿一次薪水。是的。所以你的第一张薪水是在你进入国会的第一个月末发下来的。所以，比如你是怎么度过难关的？你撑过那第一个月。
Yeah, like these are things that, and a lot of your colleagues like, don't have to think about it. Right. So it's, there's like these interesting little challenges. And are you, but I rent, I rent in New York and in DC. And you're not allowed to take money from constituents
是的，就像这些事情，你的很多同事根本不用考虑这些。对。所以，这就像有这些有趣的小挑战。而且你是，但我租房，我在纽约和华盛顿都租房。而且你不被允许从选民那里拿钱
to help you out, I'm thinking I'm putting in terms of like college athletes and stuff like you can't take money from sponsors. Yeah. Yeah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, What I do a lot to now what about shadow to amtrak back there Good for you now what about And Metro North too while we're at it I mean Bucket All right, so now did you did you want to do this from an early age? No.
来帮你的忙，我想我是从大学运动员之类的角度来考虑的，比如你不能从赞助商那里拿钱。是的。是的，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不出身，对吧，肖恩？顺便说一句，还在租房。对。不，不。
Or was it when you were working with the Bernie Sanders campaign, you saw some stuff that you thought, well, maybe that's... Yeah, well, you know, I never thought that I would be elected to public office. I also didn't think that someone like me, or with a background like mine, could really get elected to public office. I also didn't think that someone like me, or with a background like mine, could really get elected to public office. And that young, two, 29, that's young to suffer, right?
还是当你在为伯尼·桑德斯的竞选团队工作时，你看到了一些东西，让你觉得，嗯，也许那是……对的，你知道，我从未想过自己会被选为公职人员。我也没想到像我这样的人，或者有着我这种背景的人，真的能够被选为公职人员。我也没想到像我这样的人，或者有着我这种背景的人，真的能够被选为公职人员。而且那么年轻，两岁，29岁，承受这些还很年轻，对吧？
It's the youngest woman ever. I mean, you had like... Yeah. Yeah. I mean, how will three of you, when you started to get involved in your first primary or whatever? You were like 27? I was 27 when I started running.
这是有史以来最年轻的女性。我的意思是，你有过……对。对。我的意思是，你们三个人在开始参与第一次初选或类似活动时都是什么情况？你当时大概 27 岁？我开始竞选时 27 岁。
That's crazy. Yeah. I mean, 27, Sean, you were making millions of dollars a year on willing grays. You know, like everybody's got humble beginnings, right, Sean? And by the way, and still renting. Yeah. No, no.
太疯狂了。是的。我的意思是，肖恩，27 岁时，你在威林格雷斯公司每年赚数百万美元。你知道，就像每个人都有卑微的起点一样，对吧，肖恩？顺便说一句，而且还在租房。对，不，不。
No, you blew through it. Oh, I blew through it. Oh, I blew through it. Yeah. Wait, I want to know like, I don't know how any of it. Like, I'm the, like I said, the dumbest person in the world. And how, how, there is nobody disagreeing. I know.
不，你把它全花光了。哦，我把它全花光了。哦，我把它全花光了。是的。等等，我想知道，就像，我不知道这一切是怎么回事。就像我是，就像我说的，世界上最笨的人。而且怎么，怎么，没有人反驳。我知道。
Higher audience. No, there's always, always get from, whatever news source we get is how I'm probably jumping way ahead, but I just want to get this. No, please, let's get all over the place. Yeah, all we get from whatever news source we get is how I'm probably jumping way ahead, but I just wanna get to it. Please, let's get all over the place. Yeah, yeah, all we get from the TV and whatever,
更高的听众。不，总是有，总是从，不管我们从什么新闻源得到消息，就是我可能跳得太远了，但我只想弄明白这个。不，求你了，让我们海阔天空地聊吧。对，到处都是。是的，我们从电视和随便什么地方得到的所有东西，
we get our news, whatever you watch or read or whatever. You too. Is that, it's always at a standstill. Nothing gets accomplished, and we hear the same thing, and how long is it gonna go on? When are we gonna find somebody or something or anything that can make us meet in the middle? I think both sides are sick and tired of it.
我们从你观看或阅读的任何东西中获取新闻。你也是。就是，它总是陷入僵局。什么也做不成，我们听到的是同样的话，这还要持续多久？我们什么时候才能找到一个人、一件事或任何东西，能让我们在中间相遇？我觉得双方都对此感到厌烦了。
You know, like what is that thing? Yeah. Well, I mean, I think the thing is, is what we need to take a look at, is that there's a lot of meeting in the middle. It's just about the things that we don't like. So there's a lot of meeting in the middle, it's just about the things that we don't like. So there's a lot of bipartisan consensus about militarism and around Wall Street bailouts
你知道，那是什么东西？是的。嗯，我的意思是，我认为关键在于，我们需要审视的是，其实有很多在中间相遇的情况。这只是关于我们不喜欢的事情。所以有很多在中间相遇的情况，只是关于我们不喜欢的事情。所以有很多关于军国主义和华尔街救市的
and around helping out corporations and shorting the middle and working class. There's a lot that goes on that passes that gets done to advance that. That doesn't, isn't newsworthy or something, or we don't hear about it. I think, I mean, we don't, if we do hear about it, we don't like it.
两党共识，以及关于帮助企业和做空中产阶级和工人阶级的共识。有很多事情通过了，做成了，以推进这一点。这不具有新闻价值什么的，或者我们没有听说过。我认为，我的意思是，我们没有，如果我们确实听说了，我们也不会喜欢它。
But there's a lot that goes on that, you know, I just don't think, it's really about like, what are we doing to affect people's lives, and to improve people's lives in a way that's felt. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. SmartLess is supported by NetSuite by Oracle. If your business earns millions or tens of millions of revenues, stop what you're doing and take a listen because NetSuite by Oracle has just rolled out the best offer we've ever
但有很多事情正在发生，你知道，我只是不认为，这真的关乎——我们在做什么来影响人们的生活，并以一种有切身感受的方式改善人们的生活。是的。现在，听一听我们赞助商的话。SmartLess由甲骨文旗下的NetSuite支持。如果您的企业收入达到数百万甚至数千万，请停下您手上的活儿听一听，因为甲骨文旗下的NetSuite刚刚推出了我们见过的
seen. NetSuite gives you the visibility and control you need to make better decisions faster. And for the first time in NetSuite's 25 years as the number one cloud financial system, you can defer payments of a full NetSuite implementation for six months. That's no payment and no interest for six months and you can take advantage of the special financing offer
最优惠的方案。NetSuite为您提供做出更好、更快决策所需的可见性和控制力。在NetSuite作为第一大云财务系统的25年历史中，您首次可以推迟六个月支付全部NetSuite实施费用。也就是六个月内零首付、零利息，您今天就可以享受这项特殊的融资优惠。
today. NetSuite is number one because they give your business everything you need in real-time all in one place to reduce manual process, boost efficiency, build forecasts, and increase productivity across every department. Look, having all of your information in one place is kind of the name of the game, and that's what NetSuite has. More than 36,000 companies have already upgraded to NetSuite, gaining visibility and control over the financials, inventory, HR, e-commerce, and more.
NetSuite之所以成为第一，是因为它们在一个地方实时为您的企业提供您所需的一切，以减少人工流程、提高效率、建立预测并提高各个部门的生产力。听着，把所有的信息集中在一个地方可以说是成功的关键，这就是NetSuite所拥有的。已有超过36,000家公司升级到NetSuite，获得了对其财务、库存、人力资源、电子商务等的可见性和控制力。
If you've been sizing NetSuite up to make the switch, then you know this deal is unprecedented. No interest, no payments. Take advantage of the special financing offer at NetSuite.com slash smartless. NetSuite.com slash smartless to get the visibility and control you need to be dehydrated. It's not healthy. You have to hydrate all the? It's so important, it's the worst thing to be dehydrated. It's not healthy, you have to hydrate all the time. I'm doing a show, as you all know. On Broadway, I sweat like a pig when I'm on stage.
如果您一直在权衡是否要改用NetSuite，那么您就知道这项优惠是前所未有的。零利息，零首付。请在NetSuite.com/smartless利用这项特殊的融资优惠。访问NetSuite.com/smartless以获得脱水所需的可见性和控制力。这不健康。你必须时刻补水？这太重要了，脱水是最糟糕的事情。这不健康，你必须时刻补水。正如你们所知，我正在演出。在百老汇，我在舞台上像猪一样流汗。
And so I need to rehydrate, I need to get all my electrolytes so that I can continue to keep performing, right? It's just really, really important. Liquid IV, the number one powdered hydration brand in America, is now available in sugar-free. Years in the making, hydration multiplier sugar-free uses a proprietary zero sugar hydration solution with no artificial sweeteners.
所以我需要重新补水，我需要补充所有的电解质，以便我能继续表演，对吧？这真的很重要。Liquid IV，美国排名第一的粉状补水品牌，现在推出了无糖版。经过多年的研发，Hydration Multiplier无糖版采用专有的零糖补水配方，不含人工甜味剂。
With three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients for everyday wellness, liquid IV hydrates two times faster than water alone. Keep your daily routine exciting with three new flavors, white peach, green grape and lemon lime. I kind of like anything grape, so I really really like the green grape one. Liquid IV believes that equitable access to clean and abundant water is the foundation of a healthier world. They partner with leading organizations
其电解质含量是领先运动饮料的三倍，外加八种用于日常健康的维生素和营养素，Liquid IV的补水速度是单独饮用水的两倍。三种新口味白桃、青提和柠檬青柠让你的日常保持新鲜感。我挺喜欢葡萄味的，所以我非常喜欢青提味的。Liquid IV坚信，平等获得清洁和充足的水是更健康世界的基石。他们与领先组织合作
to fund and foster innovative solutions that help communities protect both their water and their futures. Real people, real flavor, real hydrating, now sugar-free. Grab your Liquid IV Hydration Multiplayer Sugar-Free and bulk nationwide at Costco or get 20% off when you go to liquidiv.com and use code SmartLess at checkout. That's 20% off anything you order when you use promo code Smartless at liquid-iv.com. I'm Rex Chapman and these days most people know me for trolling weirdos on the internet, which is fun. But believe it or not, I had a whole career before that, playing basketball in the NBA.
来资助和促进创新解决方案，帮助社区保护他们的水资源和未来。真实的人，真实的口味，真正的补水，现在推出无糖版。在全美的好市多(Costco)批量购买您的Liquid IV Hydration Multiplier无糖版，或者访问liquidiv.com并在结账时使用代码SmartLess可享受20%的折扣。在liquid-iv.com使用优惠码Smartless，您订购的任何商品均可享受8折优惠。我是雷克斯·查普曼，如今大多数人认识我是因为我在网上调侃怪人，这挺好玩的。但信不信由你，在此之前我有一整段职业生涯，在NBA打篮球。
Chapman 3-pointer outside! I played for four teams over 12 years in the league, alongside so many incredible players. But, no matter where I went, there was one guy on every team who was totally untouchable. That was the owner. Plenty of fans don't even know who owns their team, who's making the backroom deals and moving players
查普曼外线三分命中！我在联盟12年里效力过四支球队，身边有那么多不可思议的球员。但是，无论我走到哪里，每个球队都有一个人是完全不可触碰的。那就是老板。许多球迷甚至不知道谁拥有他们的球队，是谁在幕后交易并将球员
around like pieces on a game board? But every week on OLD, we're going to take the fancy elevator sneak pass security and find out what it means to be a power player in the big leagues of pro sports. I said I keep giving the money but they keep getting the same result. The families like the wealthy but on sexy Kardashians. Follow OLD wherever you get your podcast. You can listen early and have free on the Amazon Music or Wondry app. And now back to the show. So then let's say there's a subject that you would like to pull one of the Republicans over and meet in the middle and have some bipartisan consent on and then have a piece of legislation.
像棋盘上的棋子一样移来移去？但每周在《OLD》节目中，我们将乘坐豪华电梯绕过安保，去发现在职业体育的大联盟中成为权力玩家意味着什么。我说我一直给钱，但他们总是得到同样的结果。这些家庭就像富有但并不性感的卡戴珊家族。在您获取播客的任何地方关注《OLD》。您可以在Amazon Music或Wondry App上提前且免广告收听。现在回到节目中。那么，假设有一个主题，你想把其中一个共和党人拉过来，在中间相遇，达成一些两党共识，然后出台一项立法。
How does that happen? Do you call somebody who you think might be the most pliable on the other side and say, hey, let's have coffee or is it, or do you text? Yeah. How does this part work? Like, let's meet in the middle. A little bit of all of it.
这怎么发生呢？你会打电话给一个你认为对方阵营中最灵活的人，然后说，嘿，我们去喝杯咖啡吧，或者，或者发短信？是的。这部分是怎么运作的？比如，让我们在中间相遇。各种情况都有一些。
You say, do you say try this gummy and then let's talk about it. A little bit of all of it. Sometimes it's, sometimes, you know, there are group chats. Like, that's, oh yeah, that's a thing. Oh, put me in one. Yeah. Oh. I just, how bad would you love to just infiltrate and just start loving that?
你说，你会说试试这个软糖然后我们谈谈吗？各种情况都有一些。有时是，有时，你知道，有群聊。就像，哦，是的，有这回事。哦，把我加进去。是的。哦。我只是，如果你能潜入进去并开始喜欢那个，会有多糟糕？
Wait, a minute. It's sometimes like that. That's a dick pic, yeah. Yeah. But sometimes, you know, the house floor that you see on C-SPAN or at the state of the union, that's where we go to vote every day. And so it is kind of like a high school cafeteria.
等一下。有时就像那样。那是张鸡巴照，是的。是的。但有时，你知道你在C-SPAN或国情咨文中看到的众议院大厅，那是我们每天去投票的地方。所以它有点像高中食堂。
When you see you guys getting talking next one, you're not talking about sports or whatever. Like, you're saying, hey, I want to talk to you about this. I miss a little bit of this. You sign up, policy, and things you're trying to do. And maybe you should make more like a musical number. Like, make it to talk to you about this. I'm a little bit of this. You sign up policy and things you're trying to do, and maybe you should make more like a musical number. Like, make it, what do you know what I mean? In the cafeteria.
当你看到你们这些人接下来在交谈时，你们不是在谈论体育什么的。就像，你在说，嘿，我想和你谈谈这个。我怀念这一点。你报名，政策，以及你正在努力做的事情。也许你应该把它弄得更像一个音乐剧号码。就像，把它变成，我想跟你谈谈这个。我有一点这个。你报名政策和事情你试图做，也许你应该使它更像一个音乐剧编号。就像，把它变成，你知道我的意思吗？在食堂里。
5, 6, 6, 7, 8. Well, make it, Bill! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! So wait, wait, any time. Yeah.
5，6，6，7，8。好吧，把它做好，比尔！哦！哦！哦！哦！所以等等，等等，任何时候。是的。
You don't have to ask him twice. So then, it's, do you have to worry about the texting being possibly exposed by somebody like is there an encrypted chat thing for congressmen? I mean I feel like some folks they'll use they'll use, I mean they use the same things that everybody uses you know. They'll use, I mean, they use the same things that everybody uses, you know? Yeah. They'll use, they'll either use iMessage, Signal, WhatsApp, like whatever does people use. Or again, it is like a high school cafeteria where sometimes you're talking to somebody
你不用问他两遍。那么，是不是，你得担心发短信可能会被诸如国会议员是否有加密聊天工具之类的人曝光？我的意思是，我觉得有些人会用，他们会用，我的意思是，他们用每个人都在使用的东西，你知道的。他们会用，他们要么用 iMessage、Signal、WhatsApp，不管人们用什么。或者再次，它就像高中食堂，有时你在和某人交谈，
and someone be like, well, you know who you should talk to. That guy over there. And it's very informal in that way, right? Is it as right? Because I would think they're really well there. What's that? Is that the informal part? I know, I think I do really well there.
然后有人会说，你知道你应该和谁谈谈吗。那边的那个人。用这种方式非常非正式，对吧？是不是，对吧？因为我想他们在那里真的很好。什么？那是那部分非正式的吗？我知道，我觉得我在那里做得很好。
I think it was in informal. I think it would. Informal, and then you're on group chats. Yeah. And you know what I mean? It really is a lot of schmoozing. It's a lot of schmoozing, Jason. No, wait, what is it?
我想那是非正式的。我想会的。非正式的，然后你在群聊里。是的。你知道我的意思吗？这真的是很多寒暄。这有很多寒暄，杰森。不，等等，那是什么？
Can I do it? Yeah. So when people are trying to figure out since it's every, excuse me, every two years for Congress as opposed to six years senators, yes. OK, and four years for president, right? Yeah. Oh, God.
我能做吗？是的。所以当人们试图弄清楚时，因为国会是每隔，对不起，每两年一次，而不是参议员的六年一次，是的。好的，总统是四年一次，对吧？是的。哦，天哪。
I'm Canadian and I know that. I know, I know. It's a constant turnover. So how do you keep track of who might be a pliable member of the other side? And the sort of long-winded question which I'm prone to do associated with this is, tuck in.
我是加拿大人，我都知道这一点。我知道，我知道。这是一个不断的人员更替。那你怎么追踪对方阵营中谁可能是一个灵活的成员呢？我习惯于提出的那个冗长的问题，与之相关的是，收起。
Just lay back. Why are you answering your own question? Well, it's a thing. Just ask her a simple question and then let her answer it. When you got there, it's a thing. Just ask her a simple question and then let her answer it. When you got there, it was so exciting for a lot of people for many, many reasons. Did you find that you were either really embraced or not based on all the press coverage that you got the second you
躺回去。你为什么在回答你自己的问题？好吧，这是一回事。只要问她一个简单的问题，然后让她回答。当你到那儿时，这是一回事。只要问她一个简单的问题，然后让她回答。当你到那儿时，由于种种原因，这对许多人来说都非常兴奋。你发现当你一到那里时，因为你得到的所有媒体报道，你受到了热烈欢迎还是没有？
got there? Was it helpful or hurtful? It was in terms of internal dynamics. It's actually hurtful, because what happens is that you're sitting right next to a person. And it's a really bizarre experience, because so there's something called a cloakroom. Oh, here we go.
是有帮助还是有害？就内部动态而言。实际上是有害的，因为发生的情况是，你正坐在一个人的旁边。这是一个非常诡异的经历，因为有一个叫做衣帽间的东西。哦，我们来了。
And... Harry Potter! Yes! There's a lot of Harry Potter and Harry Potter stuff. It's not Harry Potter show, either. No, but he's right, it does sound dope as hell. So you have the house floor, you know, like what you see in the state of the Union.
而且……哈利·波特！是的！有很多哈利·波特和哈利·波特的东西。这也不是哈利·波特秀。不，但他是对的，这听起来确实太酷了。所以你有众议院大厅，你知道的，就像你在国情咨文中看到的那样。
But there are these rooms attached to the house floor. And there is a Democrat's cloakroom, and there's a Republican cloakroom. And so you go in through the cloakroom and there's like, you know, there's rules about being on the house floor, you can't, you can't wear coats, and so you put your back in the day, but you can't go.
但众议院大厅旁边有这些房间。有一个民主党衣帽间，还有一个共和党衣帽间。所以你穿过衣帽间进去，有，你知道的，关于在众议院大厅有规定，你不能，你不能穿外套，所以你过去把包放好，但你不能去。
But you can put, I mean, back at chewing gum. Wait, wait, wait, why can't you wear a coat on the center floor, on the, on the, on the house floor? There's pretty strict dress codes. Yeah. You cannot wear a coat. Yeah, you can't wear a coat. Yeah, you can't wear a coat. Why?
但你可以放，我的意思是，嚼口香糖。等等，等等，等等，为什么你不能在中心大厅，在，在，在众议院大厅穿外套？有着相当严格的着装要求。是的。你不能穿外套。是的，你不能穿外套。是的，你不能穿外套。为什么？
You can't wear a coat? You can't wear denim. Until very recently, women could not wear sleeveless dresses. Oh, my God. Yeah, it's old school like that. And so they had these things called cloak, their cloak rooms, where back in the day, kind of, you know, in the 1800s and whatnot,
你不能穿外套？你不能穿牛仔裤。直到最近，女性还不能穿无袖连衣裙。哦，天哪。是的，就是那种老派的风格。所以他们有这些叫做衣帽间的地方，在过去，差不多，你知道的，在19世纪等等，
members of Congress, they would drop their cloaks there. There used to be chests where you put it up and you pull out huge bottles of booze and put the booze in the thing before you went on the house floor. They don't have those anymore. They don't have those anymore, but. Booze cubbies.
国会议员，他们会在那里放下他们的斗篷。过去有箱子，你把它们放上去，然后拿出巨大瓶子的酒，在去众议院大厅之前把酒倒进那个东西里。他们现在没有那个了。他们现在没有那个了，但是。酒柜。
Yeah, I was like little cubbies. But that's how it was. And so that's like this informal socializing space. Well, Jimmy Jordan must love the house floor. Can guys go sleeveless? That's a question. That's a question from our friend Justin Theroux. Asking for a caller, JT from New York.
是的，就像小隔间。但事情就是这样的。所以这是一个非正式的社交空间。好吧，吉姆·乔丹一定很喜欢众议院大厅。伙计们可以穿无袖吗？这是一个问题。这是我们的朋友贾斯汀·塞洛克斯提出的问题。代来自纽约的打电话者JT提问。
We get it, man, your arms are really good. All right, now, so again, jumping all over the place. You talk about the floor, and then the rooms off to the size of it makes me think about, I want to go to January 6th for one second. I have a question about, why did they all leave once they got in? Is it because they couldn't find you guys? That you, that there were places where you guys were shut a lot of time. They were hiding in the cloakroom.
我们懂的，老兄，你的手臂真的很棒。好吧，现在，所以再次，到处乱跳。你谈到大厅，然后旁边房间让我想起，我想去1月6日一秒钟。我有个问题，为什么他们一进去就都离开了？是因为他们找不到你们吗？你们有很多时间被关在某些地方。他们躲在衣帽间里。
They were in the cloakroom. No, but like, like, the balloons. Was that, was that because obviously, old mister, what's his face, never called them off? So they didn't leave because of that. Did they leave because you guys were properly stowed away? Well, the thing that's interesting about the architecture of the Capitol is that like Harry Potter. Yep, like Hogwarts. It's very Byzantine. It's actually really hard to navigate and so they couldn't find the halls and the places
他们在衣帽间里。不，但是，但是，气球。那是，那是为了，显然，老先生，他叫什么名字，从来没有把他们叫走？所以他们不是因为那个离开的。他们离开是因为你们被妥善藏起来了吗？好吧，关于国会大厦的建筑结构，有趣的是，它就像哈利·波特。是的，就像霍格沃茨。它非常拜占庭式。实际上真的很难辨认方向，所以他们找不到大厅和那些地方
that you needed to navigate to where member offices were. And so they kind of like busted in, and they found some of the main offices, like Pelosi's office and House leadership's offices there. And so- Everybody was gone, everybody was gone. Everybody was taken away. Like to me, that's the unsung heroic story of all this.
你得去找议员办公室在哪里。然后他们就闯了进去，找到了几个主要的办公室，比如佩洛西的办公室和众议院领导层的办公室。然后——大家都走了，大家都走了。所有人都被带走了。在我看来，这才是整件事中不为人知的英雄故事。
Yeah, yeah. Because somebody, and it was probably the Capitol Police, did great work of putting everybody away. Yeah. And it was like, people went into rob a bank, and somebody hit all the money, and they were like, my fuck it, I guess, let's go home. We didn't know money here.
对，对。因为有人（很可能是国会警察）把大家都妥善转移了，做得太棒了。对。这就好像，有人去抢银行，结果有人把所有的钱都藏了起来，他们就像是在说，好吧管他的，我想我们回家吧。我们不知道钱在这儿。
Yeah, I knew. That was a crazy, crazy day. And I think we all were. Or was it, will? We all remember. Oh, was it, will? Well, we all remember where we were that day, Jason. Do you remember where you were?
对，我知道。那真是疯狂、疯狂的一天。我想我们所有人都是。或者说，威尔？我们都记得。哦，是吗，威尔？好吧，我们都记得那天我们在哪里，杰森。你还记得你在哪里吗？
I was with you on the golf course. Oh, God. Why'd you tear yourself up to something new? Why'd you get on your head? I knew it. You were so bad at it with me. Well, why'd you get on your head? You were so bad with me. Well, because you said it was a crazy day.
我和你在高尔夫球场上。哦，天哪。你干嘛要把自己搞得像个新状况一样？你干嘛往自己身上揽？我早就知道。你跟我在一起时表现得太差劲了。好吧，你干嘛往自己身上揽？你跟我在一起时太差劲了。好吧，因为你说那是疯狂的一天。
Well, we get it. It's funny that you talk about it, because, um, and it's funny that you bring it up kind of after, you know, discussing relationships with, uh, with, with members and Republicans and Democrats, because it right before I left, so, uh, Congress was in session this week. And so right before I left, um, they literally had the last vote of the week.
好吧，我们懂了。你谈起这个挺逗的，因为，嗯，而且你把它提出来也挺逗的，就在（你知道的）讨论了与——嗯——与——与议员们以及共和党人和民主党人的关系之后，因为就在我离开之前——所以，嗯，国会这周在开会。所以就在我离开之前，嗯，他们 literalmente 进行了这周的最后一次投票。
And I was just, you know, feeling something out. So most of the folks were kind of filed out. And some Republicans, I mean, members of Congress in general, like kind of funny people. Are they? Pretty unusual. Are they? Um, pretty usual. Are they aware of that? Yeah.
然后我当时就，你知道的，在试探情况。所以大多数人都已经陆续离开了。有些共和党人，我是说，国会议员整体上，就挺搞笑的。是吗？相当不寻常。是吗？嗯，挺平常的。他们意识到这一点吗？对。
And so the thing that's interesting is like, some Republicans are just like, the reality in front of them is like completely divorced from the rhetoric and like all this other stuff that sometimes they go on TV and say, it's really weird. And does it feel a little high school-ish where like, you know, there are people there that are obviously, I know, you don't get along with,
所以有趣的是，有些共和党人，他们眼前的现实与他们有时上电视所说的那些辞藻和所有其他东西完全脱节，这真的很诡异。这有没有点像高中文凭的感觉，就好像，你知道的，那里有些人明显是——我知道，你和他们合不来，
they don't get along with you, they can go nameless. But I mean, like, what happens when you pass her in the hallway, you know? Like, I mean, yeah, but I mean, is it, but is it really not so dissimilar from high school where you either choose to pretend they're not walking by, or is there something, is there a snotty look, is there a snotty aside?
他们也和你合不来，可以不提他们的名字。但我的意思是，当你走廊擦肩而过时会发生什么，你知道吗？就像，我的意思是，是的，但我的意思是，这难道真的跟高中没什么两样吗？你要么选择假装他们没从旁边走过，要么就是有什么冷嘲热讽的眼神，有什么刻薄的闲话？
Is there ever like, hey, you know what, let's hang out this weekend, let's like, we can fix this together. And, you know? Yeah, well, I think a lot of it is like high school. And the reason for it is I think there's just a certain dynamic when you get 400 people in a similar space.
有没有那种像“嘿，你知道吗，这周末我们一起出去玩吧，我们可以一起把这事解决。”然后呢？你知道的？对，嗯，我觉得很多地方就像高中。原因就在于，我觉得当把400个人塞进一个相似的空间里时，就会产生某种特定的动态。
And their little bells, when the bells call, the bells ring. It's like high school in a lot of ways, like just structured that way. So some people really operate that way. In second high school. Yeah. So high school is this place?
还有他们的那些小铃铛，当铃声响起时，铃声就会敲响。在很多方面就像高中，结构就是这样的。所以有些人确实是按这种方式运作的。在第二个高中。Yeah. 所以高中就是这个地方？
Yeah. Is it up a few floors? Why do they call it high? We don't have time, but we're gonna. Bubble back. And so some people conduct themselves that way. Some people actually want to get to know each other. But yeah, I mean, some, I mean, listen.
对。是在上面几层吗？他们为什么管它叫高（High，也有“嗨”的意思）？我们没时间了，但我们会回过头来的。所以有些人就是那样行事的。有些人其实是想去了解彼此。但是，好吧，我是说，有些人，我是说，听着。
But like a high school, if it was a person X and person Y, that everybody knew they didn't like each other. And then if on Monday, everyone came back to school, and the word got out like, oh, you know, over the weekend, they talked, and they're all good. It would blow the high school's mind, and everybody would come back together. So I'm just saying, I mean, I don't know.
但就像高中一样，如果有人X和人Y，所有人都知道他们互相看不顺眼。然后如果到了周一，大家又回到学校，消息传开了，比如，哦，你知道吗，周末的时候他们聊过了，现在都挺好的。这会把整个高中的脑子都震碎的，然后大家又会重新聚在一起。所以我只是说，嗯，我不知道。
It would be a really cool thing. I know you're willing. What would you say? I always hear this, well, if you don't like something call your congressman. Does that really happen? Do you guys have like voicemail that go through every day? No, it actually, okay, it depends on who the member is.
那会是一件很酷的事情。我知道你愿意。你会说些什么？我经常听到这个，嗯，如果你不喜欢什么就给你的国会议员打电话。这真的会发生吗？你们每天都有要处理的语音留言吗？不，其实，好吧，这取决于这位议员是谁。
Some of them don't care, but some of them really, really do. Especially members of Congress who are in swing seats, they're actually very sensitive to the volume of those calls, except it has to be from their constituents. So if you're just calling somebody somewhere else, they're like, I don't care what someone from so and so things. I'm, they're really resonant with their voters. So if their voters are really upset and flooding their phones,
他们中的一些人根本不在乎，但有些人的确非常、非常在乎。特别是那些处于摇摆选区的国会议员，他们对这些电话的数量其实非常敏感，除非这些电话必须来自他们的选区选民。所以如果你只是从其他什么地方打电话给某人，他们会觉得，我才不在乎某某地方的人怎么想呢。他们，他们与选民有着真正的共鸣。所以如果他们的选民真的很生气并挤爆了他们的电话，
that's, that is something, especially if you're in a tough seat that does really resonate with, with some of them. But others, they, I mean, and senators, I don't even know. But if you get a call from 718, your answer. Yes. 718, 347. 470. 212, maybe if you move. Your answer, amen. Yes, 718, 3, 4, 7, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, maybe if you move. 9 was 7, 9 was 7, 9 was 7.
那确实是一回事，特别是如果你处于一个艰难的选区，这确实会引起其中一些人的共鸣。但其他人，他们，我是说，还有参议员，我甚至都不知道。但如果你接到一个718开头的电话，你就会接。对。718, 347. 470. 212，也许如果你搬家的话。你就会接，阿门。是的，718, 3, 4, 7, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2，也许如果你搬家的话。9是7，9是7，9是7。
9 was 7. 9 was 7. That's so cool. What is it about something I have not really understood is a lot of these folks that are in positions like yourself could make a whole hell of a lot more money back in the private sector. Are and yet to keep their seat, obviously talking about a lot of folks on the other side,
9是7。9是7。太酷了。有一件事我一直没太搞懂，那就是像你这样处于这种地位的很多人，完全可以在私营部门赚到多得多的钱。然而为了保住他们的席位，显然在谈到对方阵营的很多人的时候，
to keep their seat, they have to twist themselves into these ethical knots to hold the party line. When you can kind of tell they probably wouldn't want to, like you were saying earlier, they say privately, like, were saying earlier, they say privately, like, oh, blah, blah, blah. So why are they staying there, earning, I think it's, it's, the way senators make... I mean, all members of Congress make $174,000 a year.
为了保住他们的席位，他们不得不把自己扭曲进这些道德死结里来维持党派路线。当你可以看出他们可能根本不想这么做时，就像你刚才说的，他们在私底下说，就像刚才说的，他们在私底下说，哦，啦啦啦。那他们为什么还要待在那里，赚着，我觉得是，参议员赚的……我是说，所有国会议员一年的薪水是174,000美元。
Right, and I bet you a lot of those who are, a lot of them, very skilled attorneys, could make, you know, X number of millions a year. So are they really staying there and holding their job because they have some ideology that they're so passionate about or they are so altruistic, they wanna help, you know, the public,
对，我敢打赌，其中很多人，许多技术娴熟的律师，本来可以每年赚到好几百万的。所以他们真的是因为对某种意识形态有着无比的热情，或者他们是如此无私，想要帮助，你知道的，公众，才留在那里的吗？
I don't get the sense that a lot of them do on the other side, I'm sorry to say. And so why are they there when they could be making all this money back in their district? Well, a lot of them still do make a ton of money because there's a lot of insider trading that goes on in Congress.
我感觉另一边很多人并不是这样的，很抱歉这么说。既然他们本来可以在自己的选区赚到所有这些钱，那他们为什么还要待在那里呢？好吧，他们很多人其实还是赚了一大笔钱，因为国会里存在着大量的内幕交易。
There we go. And okay, you're not supposed to. Not on my wife. I'm not supposed to like say that term. See, she's having some of the scotch guys. We're getting it now. Here's what I'm gonna say, the spirit. Like, you know, because technically folks will say,
这就对了。而且，好吧，你们本来不该这样的。不是针对我妻子。我本来不该说这个词的。看，她正在喝苏格兰威士忌呢，伙计们。我们现在进入状态了。我要说的是，这种精神。就像，你知道的，因为从技术上讲，人们会说，
you know, technically this is not a crime. Technically it's not. In spirit, it is. Like it should not exist, you know? Because their privy disinformation is coming down the pipe and they buy stock in that company. Exactly. And so it is legal.
你知道的，从技术上讲这不是犯罪。从技术上讲确实不是。但从精神上讲，这就是。就像它本不应该存在一样，你知道吗？因为他们能提前知道内幕消息即将出炉，然后他们就去买那家公司的股票。完全正确。所以它是合法的。
As a member of Congress, it is currently leaked, and I've been trying to change this. Yeah. It, as a member of Congress, it is currently legal, and I've been trying to change this. Yeah. It, as a member of Congress, it is currently legal to, I can, I have access to classified briefings, you can get things down the line, and you can buy stock in individual companies. And it can be within the purview of the committee
作为一名国会议员，目前这依然是合法的，而我一直在努力改变这一点。是的。作为一名国会议员，目前这依然是合法的，而我一直在努力改变这一点。是的。作为一名国会议员，目前这依然是合法的，我可以——我能接触到机密简报，你可以提前知道一些消息，然后你就可以购买个别公司的股票。而且这甚至可以在你所在的委员会的管辖范围内。
that you sit on. I mean, it's bonkers. So it should not be legal, and we've been working to make it illegal. And I actually think the increased public attention very recently is gonna get us some traction on this issue, knock on one. Yeah, how is that still there?
我的意思是，这太荒谬了。所以这不应该是合法的，我们一直在努力让它变成非法的。而且我真的认为，最近公众关注度的提高将在这个问题上给我们带来一些推动力，敲木头。对，这怎么还能存在呢？
That's crazy. And so not only that, but A, there's that B, there are plenty of members who are so wealthy and get elected that they don't have to, like, a salary is nothing to them. It's really, there's no trade-off here. I find the psychology of a very interesting, too, because I ask myself the same question.
这太疯狂了。所以不仅如此，而且，A，有这个情况；B，有大量的议员本身就极其富有，当选后根本不需要靠薪水，薪水对他们来说算不了什么。在这里真的没有什么利益权衡。我也觉得这群人的心理非常有趣，因为我也问过自己同样的问题。
I'm like, because the thing is, like, it's a real pain in the butt. You lose your anonymity. There's, it can be grueling. People are yelling at you. So if you have so much... Your life is threatened. I mean, why do this?
我在想，因为问题是，这真的是一件很让人头疼的事。你失去了匿名性。这可能是折磨人的。人们在冲你大喊大叫。所以如果你有这么多的……你的生命受到了威胁。我的意思是，为什么要这样做？
Because you're walking to a restaurant, and they're like, right this way. And I do think, no, but I think that there is a psychology to that where there's a certain kind of power and influence that money can't buy. And there's like a prestige that I think money can't buy that is part of the psychology of some people. Not everybody.
因为你走进一家餐厅，他们会说：“这边请。”我确实觉得，不，但我认为其中确实有一种心理机制，那就是有一种金钱买不到的权力和影响力。还有一种金钱买不到的声望，这是某些人心理的一部分。不是所有人。
There are legitimately plenty of members of Congress who are just salt of the earth, incredible, amazing human beings, Jamie Rask, and Mark Takon. You love Jamie Rask. You know, like. Wow. Yeah. Amazing.
国会里确实有大把大把的议员，他们只是脚踏实地、不可思议、了不起的伟大人类，比如杰米·拉斯金（Jamie Raskin）和马克·塔高（Mark Takano）。你很喜欢杰米·拉斯金。你知道的，比如。哇。是的。太棒了。
So, you know, it's not everybody, but they're absolutely is that out to it. So you're spending 99% of your time being super duper smart, being incredibly generous with your time and your occupation and everything. What do you do to be a dumbass? What is like, are you watching Below Deck? Are you chewing gummies like crazy? What do you do to be stupid?
所以，你知道的，并不是所有人都是这样，但这种因素绝对是存在的。所以你把99%的时间都花在表现得超级无敌聪明上，在你的时间和职业以及一切事情上都慷慨得不可思议。那你做什么来当个笨蛋？你是在看《下层甲板》（Below Deck）吗？你是在疯狂嚼软糖吗？你做什么来显得很蠢？
Okay, so I, you know, because work is so crazy and like emotional, et cetera, I have to watch like dumb television. Yeah, yeah, what's the favorite dumb? Please say Ozark when you sit up. Oh! Oh! No, right.
好吧，所以，你知道的，因为工作太疯狂、太情绪化等等，我必须看一些很蠢的电视节目。对，对，最喜欢的蠢节目是什么？当你坐直时，请说《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）！哦！哦！不，没错。
Oh, two. Fun, funny stuff. And I play... You know, Murderville though is a new show. No, I'm actually done, funny stuff. And I play... You know, Murderville, though, is a new show. I know. I'm actually excited about that. No.
哦，两个。有趣，好玩的东西。我在玩……你知道《谋杀维尔》（Murderville）是一个新节目吧。不，我其实看完了，挺好玩的。我在玩……你知道《谋杀维尔》其实是个新节目吧。我知道。我其实挺兴奋的。不。
I legitimately, I saw the first commercial for like a dare to ago and I'm like, oh, this looks really funny. That shows rap, by the way. Yes, seriously watch Murderville. Very good. Don't watch it streaming on Netflix right now. It's not a big deal. It's really, really good.
我真的，大概在一两前看到它的第一支广告时，我就想，哦，这看起来太搞笑了。顺便说一句，那个节目很棒。是的，认真去看《谋杀维尔》。非常棒。现在不要在网飞（Netflix）上串流观看它。这没什么大不了的。它真的，真的很棒。
It is good. It is good. Thank you. You see the way I take the high road guys? I know. Yeah. Jay, is there. So she's going to answer what her favorite dumb show is.
它确实不错。它确实不错。谢谢。你们看我走高姿态的方式了吗？我知道。对。杰，那是……所以她要回答她最喜欢的蠢节目是什么。
OK. OK. Um, oh man. Well, I don't know. I mean, I've watched like COVID selling sunset was one of the selling sunset. I also play video games, PC games, so League of Legends, League of Legends, nice.
好的。好的。嗯，天哪。好吧，我不知道。我是说，我看过像——新冠期间看过《日落豪宅》（Selling Sunset），那是其中一个——《日落豪宅》。我也玩电子游戏，PC游戏，比如《英雄联盟》，《英雄联盟》，太棒了。
Like, yeah, no one knows what that is. And we will be right back. Since his death in 2009, the world has struggled with how Michael Jackson should be remembered, as the King of Pop, or as a monster. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator. Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what
就像，是的，没人知道那是什么。我们马上回来。自从2009年去世以来，全世界一直在争论应该如何记住迈克尔·杰克逊：是作为流行音乐之王，还是作为恶魔。我是莱昂·内法赫（Leon Neyfakh），《Fiasco》的主持人和《Slow Burn》的共同创作者。我是杰·斯穆斯（Jay Smooth），一位嘻哈记者和文化评论员。迈克尔·杰克逊在1993年首次被指控猥亵儿童。我们的新播客《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》（Think Twice, Michael Jackson）讲述了这一切发生之前和发生之后的故事。在整个播客中，我们探讨了是什么让迈克尔·杰克逊似乎“不可取消”，并深入探讨了我们许多人在杂货店听到《比利·简》（Billie Jean）时那种复杂的情感。通过对那些亲历这一故事发展的见证者的数十次独家采访，《三思》试图将我们对迈克尔·杰克逊这个人的矛盾情感，与我们对他艺术的骨子里的热爱调和起来。在您获取播客的任何地方收听《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》，或者您可以在 Audible 或亚马逊音乐应用上无广告地连续狂听整个系列。现在回到节目中。有时候我喜欢看伟大的喜剧。我最喜欢的一部是他们拍的一部电影，我们的一位朋友，我们共同的一位朋友在里面。不，不。而这个人在我最喜欢的喜剧电影、喜剧三部曲之一里，不是他。哦等等。但他们无论如何都得感谢他。
came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly un-cancelable, and we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store. Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art. Listen to think twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge
好吧。就是他。女士们先生们，我们的朋友想打个招呼，而我们来这里只是为了。好吧，所以。所以，我觉得你非常。他的绝招是，他的绝招是当电工。顺便说一句，杰，我完全不知道。我完全不知道。我知道，我知道。完全不知道 你做得很好。我看到你触碰我的作品了。你做得很好。来吧。所以布莱德利打来电话说，他说，我听说，他说，我听说你们要来这个镇上。让我们一起出去玩吧，因为他是——我们四个人是非常非常好的朋友。
the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon music app. And now back to the show. Sometimes I like to watch great comedies. One of my favorite is a film they made a few of that one of my friends, a mutual friend of ours, is in. No, no. And this guy who is in one of my favorite comedy movies, comedy trilogies, it's not him. Oh wait. But they must thank him anyway.
我们说，好吧，我们在这个镇上只待几分钟。他说，好吧，让我在演出前过来打个招呼吧。我说，不行，那他们就知道嘉宾是谁了。我说，我们唯一有空的时间就是在舞台上。所以请出来打个招呼吧。我只想说一件事，然后我就走。你哪里也不去。你哪儿也去不了。这些人我全都认识。我在1998年遇到了威尔，然后在2000年通过《双面女间谍》（Alias）认识了肖恩，接着我遇到了巴宾。
Alright. It is him. Ladies and gentlemen, our friend wanted to say hi and we're only in town to do. All right, so. So, I think you're very much. His move is, his move riding is an electrician. By the way, Jay, I have no idea. I have no idea. I do, I do. No idea You're doing well. I have seen you touching my work. You're doing well. Come on. So Bradley called and he said, he said, I hear, he said, he said, I hear you guys are coming to town. Let's all hang out because he's were all the four of us are very very good friends
这些家伙当了20年的神枪手了。你知道我们怎么说吗？谁是房间里反应最快的人，我们会说，谁是房间里反应最快的人？杰森·巴宾；谁是世界上最搞笑的人？威尔·阿奈特；谁是有史以来最搞笑的人？肖恩·海斯。所以我认识你20年了。我认识你20年了。所以他们能把自己的技能与你分享，简直不可思议。我们多幸运啊！
And we said well, we're only in town for a few minutes. He said well, let me come by and say hi before the show And I said well no, then they're gonna know the guests. I said the only time we got is on stage So please come out and say hi I just want to say one thing and then I'll leave. You're not leaving anywhere. You're not going anywhere. I've known all of these people. I met Will in 1998, and then I met Sean through Alias in 2000, and then I met Babin.
这绝对是事实，伙计。好吧，我和布莱德利曾在加利福尼亚州威尼斯市一起生活过，当时就像是……我以前天天看这个。这太疯狂了。所以，让我们进入故事的那一部分吧。所以，你会觉得这很有趣。所以，听着，给我们讲讲你们两个住在威尼斯市的经历吧，那到底是怎么回事？
And these guys have all been gun slingers for 20 years. You know what we say? Who's the quickest guy in the room, we say like, who's the quickest guy in the room? Jason Bayman, who's the funniest guy in the world? Will or not, who's the funniest guy ever, Sean Hayes? So I've been you for 20 years. I've been you for 20 years. So it's so unbelievable that they're sharing their skill set with you. How lucky are we?
所以，布莱德利住在那个物业的后面。他住在后栋房子里。你们当时多大？我们10岁。我们非常年轻。我是说，我现在演38岁，所以。算算数，最多最多。最多。
It's just the truth, man. Well, and I've lived together in Venice, California, and it was like, I used to watch this every day. It's like crazy. So, let's get into that part of the story. So, you're gonna find this interesting. So, listen, tell us about you two living together, and Venice, what was that all about?
23岁。我记得我第一次见他是在你的地方，在你的公寓里。打牌。对，在你的公寓里打牌，那是你住在后面的时候。然后我就像——你当时说，我和我的朋友布莱德利，然后你开门时身上挂着箱子。
So, Bradley lived in the back of this property. He lived in the back house. How old were you? We were 10. We were very young. I mean, I play 38 now, so. To the math, at the most. At the most.
我就像：你好。那就像是——但你开门总是这样，对吧？你好。你好。所以布莱德利住在——我们在后面有一栋楼，我们的朋友也住在那儿，我们跟罗恩·里夫金（Ron Rifkin）住在一起，我和我兄弟住在一起。然后布莱德利和我——所以布莱德利住在——我们在后面有一栋楼，我们的朋友也住在那儿。我们跟罗恩·里夫金住在一起。罗恩·里夫金就住在房子的正后方。
23. I remember the first time I met him was at your place, at your apartment. Playing cards. Yeah, playing cards at your apartment, and that's when you lived in the back. And I was like, you were like, me, my friend Bradley, and you answered the door with boxes on it.
然后布莱德利和我合住了这栋楼。在后面，我们的门是连着的。是开着的。我们俯瞰着。有一处物业，我们从他的房子顶部俯瞰。是的，老兄。我们以前有时会在小巷里看到他。没错。
I was like, hello. That was like, but that's how you always answer the door, right? Hello. Hello. And so Bradley lived in the, we had this building in the back and we had our friends, we lived with Ron Rifkin, and I lived with my brother. And then Bradley and I so Bradley lived in the, we had this building in the back and we had our friends. We lived with Ron Rifkin. Ron Rifkin was right in the back of the house.
开着那辆老捷豹。然后那感觉太棒了，那是加州，老兄。拜托。然后我们当时在拍《随性所欲》（Arrested Development），就在你拍《厨房机密档案》（Kitchen Confidential）的同一个片场。 Kitchen confidential。但另一件事是，我们是一起经历过这一切的。这才是真正的事。我们才刚刚起步。我们曾经谈论过我们的梦想，而我们
And then Bradley and I shared this building. And the back and our doors were connected. We're open. And we overlooked. There's a property we overlooked at the top of his house. Yeah, old boy. And we used to see him sometimes in the alley. That's right.
本以为永远无法实现它们。他和我都——我的意思是，这其实非常感人。我们在后台时就在想，你知道的，去实现它们。他和我都——我的意思是，这就像，这其实非常感人。我们在后台时就在想，你知道的，只要你花时间去努力，这一切就会发生。这是可能的。
Driving that old Jaguar. And then it was so, it was California, man. Come on. And then we were doing a rested at the same lot that you were doing, kitchen confidential. Kitchen confidential. But the other thing is we've all been through it together. That's really the thing. We were started out. We used to talk about our dreams, and we'd
不过其中最棒的部分是，当你和自己爱的人一起完成它时。那感觉真是太欣慰了。我有点自豪地讲过这个故事，对吧？我是说，你做到了。是的，但这是真的。100%是这样。所以，我有点自豪地讲了这个故事。他在我的——是的，但是先生。100%是这样。我的意思是，这太，呃。
never be able to fulfill them. And he and I, I mean, it's actually very emotional. We were backstage just thinking, you know, to fulfill them. And he and I, I mean, it's like, it's actually very emotional. We were backstage just thinking, you know, if you just take the time and you work hard, it can happen. It is possible.
我有点自豪地讲了这个故事。他在我的房子里。那是很多很多年以前的事了。他当时说，嘿，我接到电话要去百老汇演这部音乐剧，你能帮我弹一下这些歌吗。我当时就想，当然可以，你跑百老汇去演什么音乐剧啊？他说，我不知道。
And the best part about it though, is when you do it with people you love. And that's was just so gratifying. I proudly say this story a bit, right? I mean, you did it. Yes, but it's true. 100% way. So, I proudly say this story. He was at my Yes, but sir. 100% way. I mean, it is so, uh.
我说，你大概有18部电影要上映呢。他说，我不知道其中哪部能火，巴拉巴拉。然后简直就像，我当时说，我们正在弄这些东西。他在唱歌。然后我就想，这太棒了，我们吃了午饭什么的。然后大概一个月后，《宿醉》（The Hangover）上映了。我就想：你这个混蛋。泰，对。
I'd probably say this story. He was at my house. This is years and years and years ago. And he's like, hey, I got called to do this musical on Broadway, where you play through the songs for me. And I was like, sure, what are you doing in musical on Broadway for? He's like, I don't know.
对。对。对，这挺有意思的，你知道的，因为我们确实有机会去做——就像我们以这种方式做这件事简直太离奇了。但这完全是关于，你还记得吗，我们在后台谈到要铭记你来自何方，曾经多么艰难诸如此类的事情。
I go, you got like 18 movies coming out. He's like, I don't know if any of them will work, blah, blah. And like literally, I said, we're working on this stuff. And he's singing. And I'm like, this is great, we ate lunch and ever. And then like a month later, the hangover came out. I'm like, you're such an asshole. Ty, yeah.
布莱德利，他执导了《一个明星的诞生》（A Star Is Born）。我的意思是，太不可思议了。我们在拉斯维加斯，布莱德利在那里揭幕预告片。我在台上，我有幸介绍了他。他是所有华纳兄弟媒体活动的司仪，这是最难的工作。他当时就……是的。布莱德利上台了，我们做了这个环节，他播放了这个预告片。我们和这群观众坐在一起，场面和这里差不多，我们就坐在舞台边缘。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it's funny, you know, because we do get to do, like this is so bizarre that we're doing this in this way. But it is all about, you remember, we were talking backstage about remembering where you came from and how hard it was and all that kind of stuff.
这个预告片放映了，真的很感人，伙计。真的很棒。能够和自己爱的人一起做这件事，感觉太棒了。对，对，对。所以，是的。好吧，我只能想象。法案就是这样变成法律的。对。对。
And Bradley, he directed a star's born. And I mean, incredible. And we were in Vegas and Bradley was unveiling the trailer. And I was on stage and I got to introduce him. He was the MC for all of the Warner Bros. media, which is the hardest job. He was like, yeah. And Bradley came out and we did this thing and he played this trailer. We sat there with this crowd, not unlike this, and we sat at the end of the stage.
噢。对。呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！呜！
And this trailer played and it was emotional, man. It was really well. And it's so great to be able to do that with people you love. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So yeah. Well, I can only imagine. And that's how a bill becomes a law. Yeah. Yeah.
我简直无法想象，当你知道朋友为了达到那个目标经历了什么时，去庆祝他的胜利会有多么充实，会有多么深厚和欣慰的感受。你知道的，你并不是在某人处于巅峰时遇到他们，有时候你遇到他们时，他们正处于人生最低谷。我很高兴你提到了《少狼2》（Teen Wolf 2），因为……笑声 笑声 我这需要很大的勇气。
Oh. Yeah. Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo! Woo!
她确实需要。威廉。威廉。她根本没说过这个。她没说过。噢，好吧，我没说。算了，算了，算了，算了。我为那部电影试镜了两次。
I can only imagine how fulfilling, like, how much deeper and gratifying it is to be able to celebrate a friend's victory when you know like how, what they went through to get that. You know, you're not meeting someone at the peak when you've met someone when they were just, you know, at their lowest sometimes. I'm glad you mentioned Teen Wolf 2 because... LAUGHTER LAUGHTER I took a lot of guts.
你做到了。我得到了回电。我得到了回电。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。
She did. Will. Will. She never said that. She didn't say it. Oh, okay, I didn't say it. Forget it, forget it, forget it, forget it. I auditioned twice for that movie.
我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。
You did it. I got a callback. I got a callback. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back.
我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我要回去了。我想知道那个答案，然后你最喜欢的共和党人是谁？好吧，好吧。好问题。我喜欢这个问题，对。
I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back.
所以，我的意思是，当然有阿亚娜·普雷斯利（Ayanna Pressley）、拉希达·塔莱布（Rashida Tlaib），简直是不可思议。但还有，你知道的，我以前在餐厅工作和在市中心当酒保时的很多朋友——那些才是真正跟我生死与共的朋友。我以前在餐厅工作和在市中心当酒保时的朋友。那些也是跟我生死与共的人，他们依然是我周围最重要的一些人。如果你要在华盛顿特区出去玩并好好释放一下压力，因为那是个艰难的一周，你会给谁打第一个电话？好吧。释放压力。
I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna go back. I want to know that answer, and then who is your favorite Republican? Okay, okay. Good question. I like that question, yeah.
好吧，我觉得他是另一个……我以前有一些成瘾问题，伙计们。所以我觉得是纽约的另一位国会议员，蒙代尔·琼斯（Mondaire Jones）。对。他真的很有趣。你知道，这只是……我的意思是，有很多人都是……
So I mean, of course, there's Ayanna Pressley, Rashida Tzli, like just absolutely incredible. But also, you know, a lot of my friends from when I was working in restaurants and bartending downtown, like those are my ride or die. my friends from when I was working in restaurants and bartending downtown. Like those are my ride or die as well and those are still the people around me that are most some of the most important people. If you were going to go out and DC and really release the valve because it was a tough week, who's the first call? Okay. Release the valve.
好吧，谁最有可能跟你击掌？击掌。谁会击掌？我敢打赌是个共和党人。对，我觉得是个共和党人。因为米奇·麦康奈尔（Mitch McConnell）看起来超级随和。对。他看起来确实是个有趣的人。
Okay, I think he's another... I had some addiction problems, guys. So I think another congressman from New York, Mondair Jones. Yeah. He's really fun. You know, there's just... I mean, there's just a lot of folks who are...
对，对，对。就共和党人而言，会击掌的有田纳西州的蒂姆·伯切特（Tim Burchett），他是个喜欢击掌的人。嗯哼。有些人是喜欢击掌的。谁喜欢拥抱？有一个人。
Well, it would be the most likely to give you a high five? High five. Who's a high five? I bet it's a Republican. Yeah, I think a Republican. Because Mitch McConnell seems super easy. Yeah. He does seem like a fun guy.
哇，喜欢拥抱的人。我喜欢拥抱。你喜欢拥抱？你可以的。我尽量不成为那种——我总是，你知道的，在拥抱之前先确保对过磁场。对，我不说话。布莱德利，你会——你有没有可能竞选公职？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So as far as Republicans go, high fivers, Tim Birchett of far as Republicans go, high fiverr's Tim Birchett of Tennessee, he's a high fiverr. Mm-hmm. There's some folks who are high fiverr. Who's the hugger? There's a whore.
是的，拜托，拜托。拜托。你这么说真搞笑，因为我本来也许想说，如果我们有机会聊聊的话，但你决定做的事情，真的，你为自己的人生所决定的事情，是一个人能做的最无私的事。每个人都在谈论这个。这不是真的。
Whoa, hugger. I'm a hugger. You're a hugger? You're allowed to. I try not to be a, I always, you know, make sure I do the vibe check before I hug. Yeah, I do not talk. Bradley, would you, could you ever run for office?
不，但你可以谈论，我们对某事有多坚信，我们跟那些会赞同我们的朋友交谈，但走出去说：“我要为了我所信仰的我们所有人、我们国家的更广大利益，牺牲我的生活、我的隐私、甚至潜在的福祉，”这就好像，
Yes, come on, come on. Come on. It's funny you say that because I was going to maybe say if we had a chance to talk, but what you've decided to do, really, what you've decided to do with your life is the most selfless thing one can do. Everybody talks about it. That's not true.
就是这个，就是这样。就是这样。所以。对。话虽如此，你最喜欢的电影是什么？我得对那个做出回应。从他的开始，然后我们绕一圈。你们也可以畅所欲言。
No, but what you can be talk about, how much we believe in something, and we talk to our friends who will agree with us, but to get out there and say, I'm going to sacrifice my life, my privacy, my well-being potentially, for what I believe in the greater good of all of our in our country, it's like,
不过我必须说，我们在华盛顿特区开启了整个巡演，而且，你知道的，再次强调，我敢打赌，是的。而且，你知道的，我以前和丈夫斯科蒂去过那一次。我们只是去得太快了。我们什么也没看到，但这次和这些家伙一起的旅行，我们实际上四处走了走，我们拿了那些小“小鸟”自行车（Bird bikes），像白痴一样到处骑，而且，而且，而且，那里的枪手不如，那里的枪手，枪手，枪手。所以，你知道的，再次强调，像个白痴，我当时就想，哇，能够来到这里，我感到非常荣幸——我确信每个人都这么说——但仅仅是身处其中、没有去参观过、对它一无所知，就会觉得，哇，那里有如此多的历史，当你去到那里、亲眼看到它、亲手触摸到它时，会产生如此多的敬意。
this is it, that's it. That's it. So. Yeah. Having said that, what are your favorite movies? I have to say to that. And start with his, and then we're gonna go all the way around. And feel free to go with you guys.
是的，老兄，那是国会大厦，简直不可思议。不。肖恩一直在说，他一直在说，他在路上了。所以这是什么地方？
I have to say, though, we kicked off this whole tour in DC, and, you know, again, I bet, yeah. And, you know, I went there once with my husband, Scotty. We just were there so super fast. We didn't get to see anything, but this trip with these guys, we actually walked around and we got those little bird bikes that we drove around like idiots and, and, and, and, there's shooters not as good as, there's shooters, shooters, shooters. And so, you know, again, idiot, I was just like, wow, I was so humbled to be, I'm sure everybody says this, but just not being there, not visiting
这里是他们制定法律的地方。等一下。这里是他们制定的，他当时就像是，字面意思，他们在这里制定法律。他们在这里制定法律，他们在这里制定法律。对，伙计们，我们当时就想：是的，我们知道，老兄。我喜欢这个。这个故事你会看到在黑暗中，你会看到那个，我当时简直就像：噢，看那个，然后是一面墙。不，我只是想知道——你有没有可能竞选公职？
and not knowing anything about it, is like, wow, there's so much history, and so much respect once you go there and see it and see it in your hands. Yeah, man, it's the capital, it's just incredible. No. Sean kept going, he kept going, he's on his way. So what is this place?
看着我，当然。笑声 顺便说一句，我很伤心。我可悲地，可悲地，顺便说一句，我看到……我已经活了，我不知道，经历了五六位总统。有一位特定的总统，我不会说是谁，我看到他在一场选举中获胜。我当时就想：如果那家伙能赢，我简直也能赢。
This is where they make the laws. Wait a second. This is where they make, and he's like, literally, they make the laws there. They make the laws there they make the laws Right the guys we're like yeah, we know man. I like this And the story you'll see it in the dark you'll see that and I literally is like oh look at that and then a wall No, I just wanted it could Could you ever run for office?
笑声 是的。对，对。我看到他在一场选举中赢了，我就想：如果那家伙能赢，我简直也能赢。哦。对。对。我是说，我会投肖恩一票。上吧。肖恩当总统。总得有人制作——求求了，你们谁去制作一些帽子，上面写着
Look at me, of course. LAUGHTER By the way, I'm sad. I'm sadly, sadly, by the way, I saw... I've been alive now for, I don't know, five or six presidents. And one particular president, I won't say who it is, I saw a win in an election. I was like, if that guy can win, I literally can win.
“我会投肖恩一票”。我知道我是加拿大人。那太充满指责意味了。顺便说一句，两边你都可以支持，所以滚开。他们全都——滚开。这边的聪明鬼。噢，天哪，别把他们惹毛了，伙计们。我有一个。
LAUGHTER Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I saw a win in an election. I was like, if that guy can win, I literally can win. Oh. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I'd vote for Sean. Let's go. Sean for president. Somebody needs to make, please, one of you make hats that
他今天表现得可真好。我知道。不过我能感觉到。我可能在这边翘着脚像个摇滚巨星。你正在致力于通过的、或者你最最热衷、最想看到它通过的法律是哪一条？
say I'd vote for Sean. I know I'm Canadian. That was so accusatory. You could have on both, by the way, so suck it. They were all suck it. Smarty pants over here. Oh boy, don't get them riled up, guys. I have one.
我说我会投肖恩一票。我知道我是加拿大人。这也太指责性了。顺便说一句，你两个都可以选，所以认命吧。他们都在认命。这边这个自作聪明的家伙。噢天哪，别把他们惹毛了，伙计们。我有一个。
He's been really well behaved. I know. I could feel it, though. I could be a rock stew with a foot over here. What is the one law that you're working on or one that you more than anything that you're really, really passionate about that you really wanna see go through?
他表现得一直很好。我知道。不过我能感觉得到。我可能会在这儿当个绊脚石。你正在致力于哪一项法律，或者说哪一项是你最热衷、最希望看到它通过的？
I mean, there's so many. Medicare for all is a big one. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, this like, janky healthcare system that we have in the United States, the fact that we are so-called most developed, wealthiest country in the world,
我是说，有太多了。全民医保是一个重头戏。对。对。我是说，我们美国这种破烂的医疗系统，作为一个自称最发达、最富有的国家，
and we also have the highest maternal mortality rate of the developed world. I mean, this is ridiculous. It's kind of embarrassing. It absolutely isn't embarrassing. And I think COVID also showed a lot of that too. Like, the whole rest of the world is like, y'all live like that?
我们的孕产妇死亡率竟然也是发达国家中最高的。我是说，这太荒谬了。这有点尴尬。这绝对非常尴尬。而且我觉得新冠疫情也暴露了许多这方面的问题。就像，全世界其他地方都在想，你们居然那样生活？
Like, really? It's exciting exciting though when you see something get done that's immediate either through executive action or or or or or something similar to how did you have speaking of which how did you get she's response to get over a billion dollars was sent to reimburse the families of people who lost somebody during covid for COVID for the funeral costs. Yeah. Like, you were behind that.
真的吗？不过，当你看到某些事情通过行政命令或类似的方式立即办成时，还是挺让人兴奋的。说到这个，你是怎么让她的回应转化为送出超过十亿美元，来为在新冠疫情期间失去亲人的家庭报销丧葬费用的？是的。就像，你推动了这件事。
Like, that's incredible. And it was done like that. Yeah. I mean, that was really gratifying. And I think it's a perfect example of governance and public governance, working the way that it should work. So when COVID first hit, it hit New York City, it was one of the first places that got hit super intensely.
这太不可思议了。而且就这样完成了。是的。我是说，这真的很有成就感。我认为这是公共治理、政府治理应有工作方式的一个完美例子。所以当新冠疫情刚爆发时，它袭击了纽约市，这里是最先受到极其猛烈冲击的地方之一。
And out of all of New York City, and out of the entire country, out of the top 10 most impacted, most hit zip codes in the country by COVID, five of them were in my district. And this was at the onset of the pandemic when people still didn't even know what was going on. We didn't know how it spread.
在整个纽约市，在整个国家，在全美受新冠疫情冲击最严重、受打击最大的前十个邮政编码区中，有五个在我的选区。这正值大流行的初期，当时人们甚至还不知道发生了什么。我们不知道它是如何传播的。
So it's great. We didn't know anything about it. And what we saw was that there was a neighborhood in our district, in our community, in East Elmhurst, in Queens, and they were saying, this is hitting us really hard. And it's hitting frontline workers harder, it's hitting, you know, people whose jobs are public facing,
所以这很棒。我们对它一无所知。我们看到的是，在我们选区的某个社区，在我们的社区，在皇后区的东埃姆赫斯特，他们说，这对我们的打击太大了。它对一线工人的打击更大，对那些工作需要直接面对公众的人的打击更大，
food service workers, hospital workers, you know, retail workers, like it's hitting us hardest. And we can't even afford to bury the people that have- I don't believe it happened. I don't believe it happened. What? But this is, and I guess probably a lot of people
餐饮服务人员、医院员工、零售员工，你知道的，它对我们的打击最重。我们甚至连埋葬那些……的人的钱都没有。我不相信这发生过。我不相信这发生过。什么？但这是，我想可能很多人
want to know also, was the baby real. And the hangover, sorry, this is for Bradley. Are they men? They hangover. They're men American sniper. American sniper. Why would you bring that up? Why would you bring that up again?
也想知道，那个婴儿是真的吗？在《宿醉》里，抱歉，这是针对布莱德利的。他们是男人吗？《宿醉》。他们是男人。《美国狙击手》。《美国狙击手》。你为什么要把这个提出来？你为什么要把这个再次提出来？
I like both. I like both. Can't get over it. I love Americans. I'm building that. I'm gonna have money for the baby. You know, I don't want to tell you. I moved his hand. I mean, I made it work.
我都喜欢。我都喜欢。挥之不去。我爱美国人。我在建那个。我会有钱给那个婴儿。你知道的，我不想告诉你。我动了他的手。我是说，我让它成功了。
I moved it to that. But you recognize that you put it up front and got it done. Yeah, so folks in our community, they said, listen, this is gonna, this is like a huge cost, and we're gonna need help. And so we took that, I brought it to the House Democratic Caucus, I brought it to the speaker, I brought it to our center, Chuck Schumer, to like anyone who was listening.
我把它移到了那个。但你承认你把它摆在前面并搞定了。是的，所以我们社区的人说，听着，这将会，这就像是一笔巨大的开销，我们需要帮助。所以我们采纳了，我把它带到了众议院民主党党团会议，我把它带给了议长，我把它带给了我们的参议员查克·舒默，带给了任何愿意听的人。
I was like, we need to do this. And it took a little while. It was an immediate. It took a lot of work. But we were able to authorize in total $8 billion for rent to reimburse any funds. I'm unbelievable. Unbelievable.
我说过，我们需要这样做。这花了一点时间。这不是立竿见影的。这需要大量的工作。但我们最终能够总共授权了80亿美元的租金补贴来报销任何资金。我真不敢相信。真不敢相信。
For anybody who wants someone to go COVID. I'm amazing. It's not. Unbelievable. Unbelievable. For anybody who wants to go COVID. Amazing. It's not means tested. There's no like crazy, you know, there's no income thresholds, nothing. Like this is impacting all of us. We're all in this together. We're all going to help each other.
给任何想去新冠的人。我很棒。不是的。难以置信。难以置信。给任何想去新冠的人。太棒了。它不是按资产审查的。没有什么疯狂的，你知道的，没有收入门槛，什么都没有。这影响着我们所有人。我们都在这条船上。我们要互相帮助。
No questions asked. Well, we don't want to take any more of your valuable time. You can continue please the incredible work that you're doing. Thank you for taking a little time out, hanging out with us. Ladies and gentlemen, you can continue please the incredible work that you're doing. Thank you for taking a little time out, hanging out with us.
毫无疑问。好吧，我们不想再占用你宝贵的时。你可以继续你正在做的不可思议的工作。谢谢你抽出一点时间，和我们在一起。女士们先生们，你可以继续你正在做的不可思议的工作。谢谢你抽出一点时间，和我们在一起。
Ladies and gentlemen, Alexandra Acacia Cortez. Thank you for having me. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you, Senator. Thank you.
女士们先生们，亚历山大·奥卡西奥-科尔特斯。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢，参议员。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you, everyone. Thank you. Wow. You guys, AOC! AOC! You can go too. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢大家。谢谢。哇。你们太棒了，AOC！AOC！你也可以走了。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no We have an announcement to make. Smartlis is now four people. Yeah. Come on. I mean, we couldn't make his deal, but he did say he'd stop by. Bradley, you could do it.
不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不无。我们有个公告要宣布。Smartlis现在有四个人了。是的。来吧。我是说，我们没法谈成他的交易，但他确实说过他会顺道过来。布莱德利，你可以做到的。
You're very familiar with the show now. I love the show, you know. Right, you've just gotten caught up on all the episodes. Yeah. Oh, murder bill. Oh, murder bill. Oh, murder bill. Oh! Oh!
你现在对这个节目非常熟悉了。我喜欢这个节目，你知道的。没错，你刚刚赶上了所有的剧集。是的。哦，谋杀法案。哦，谋杀法案。哦，谋杀法案。哦！哦！
You guys thank you for, were you done, Angel? No, I don't think so. I was just talking to Bradley. Oh, good. To Bradley. I got a heart out. Where are you going? Go ahead.
你们谢谢，安杰尔，你结束了吗？不，我不觉得。我只是在和布莱德利说话。哦，很好。对布莱德利。我有一个硬性截止时间。你要去哪？说吧。
It's better be good. I wanted to say about AOC that it was, first of all, I can't believe you got her Jason to come down and chat with us. Yeah. And yeah, I mean, she's a game changer. I want to be kind, you know, like you said in your intro, just a one-of-a-kind.
最好是好事。我想说的是关于AOC的，首先，杰森，我真不敢相信你能请她下来和我们聊天。是的。而且，是的，我是说，她是一个改变游戏规则的人。我想变得友善，你知道的，就像你在开场白里说的那样，绝对是独一无二的。
And I got nervous, meaning her, because, you know, she's super smart, and I didn't wanna ask them questions, but I did anyway. Yeah. But she wasn't judging you. I thought that you were doing that back there, right? You think so? Yeah.
而且我见到她时很紧张，我的意思是，因为，你知道的，她超级聪明，我本不想问他们问题，但我还是问了。是的。不过她并没有评判你。我以为你在后面也是这么做的，对吧？你这么觉得吗？是的。
Yeah. No, she's, we're very, very like, look, whether you agree with her or disagree with her, it's undeniable that the people, as Bradley, you said, that are taking their time. choosing to spend their, like, frontline workers, which I think we have some here tonight, perhaps, yes. Yeah. I mean, it's like, thank you guys.
是的。不，她，我们非常，非常，听着，不管你同意她还是不同意她，不可否认的是，正如布莱德利你所说的那样，人们花时间，选择把他们的，比如一线工作者，我想我们今晚这里也有一些，也许吧。是的。我的意思是，谢谢你们。
And, you know, we know that we're, you know, a safety sense from smart. And we're just doing dumb chat crap that hopefully you guys enjoy listening to when you're in the middle of doing stuff that's really important. So, you know. Yeah, no. Yeah, we do this as a goof. We started this as a goof, and we're so lucky that you guys listen to us on a weekly basis.
而且，你知道，我们知道我们在安全感上很聪明。我们只是在做一些愚蠢的聊天废话，希望你们在做非常重要的事情的时候喜欢听。所以，你知道。是的，不。是的，我们这样做是为了好玩。我们一开始就是为了好玩才做这个的，我们很幸运，你们每周都会听我们的节目。
We feel, and even we can have people like our guests tonight, and no matter where you fall on either side, we can all come together on a night like this in a... Bye! On a day! Bye! Woo! Thank you very much. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
我们觉得，甚至我们可以请到今晚嘉宾这样的人，无论你站在哪一边，我们都可以在这样一个夜晚聚在一起……再见！在这一天！再见！呜！非常感谢。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisantly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umbjerf. Smite, loss. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartLess 是由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Umbjerf 100% 有机且经手工制作的。Smite, loss。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。